hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to a brand new indie horror
game called the briefcase I actually
don't know much more about it then that
is the briefcase I didn't get anything
besides just the download link there was
a trailer there but I didn't want to
spoil anything so um there's a link in
the description below if you want to
play it yourself but I'm actually wonder
if there's something wrong because I
don't hear anything
yep headphones are on anyway so I don't
really know I don't really know move
sprint crash pretty much standard why is
use enter why would you as we enter
that's silly
that's just silliness but could use as
enter anyway find the briefcase and get
out okay seemed good enough for me
though kind of pretty
I like it I don't know if there's made
on the dog can't go that way I don't
know if there's made on the unity engine
or what is that 7th Street out there huh
there's one of the bands that was
blocking the with it is I don't think
this is in any way based on slender or
anything like that
goo'bye can climb myself well I can jump
pretty high okay this looks good I like
the look at this now yeah oh not locked
what's that cracking them off yeah I
don't like the look at this I don't have
any flashlights or anything come on
going into a decrepit old building you
at least carry a frigging flashlight I
really don't know if this is like based
on any other game mythos or legends I
think it's just its own things - very
standalone I actually don't know what
the name of the guy who made it I
normally read or um thank the guy who
made it but I don't know who it is so
I'm hoping at the end they'll be some
credits or something oh this looks good
I like to look at this you've been in
warehouse actually you know what this
reminds me of it reminds me of the
warehouse towards the what was that
towards the end of afraid of monsters hi
is anybody out there
does anybody wanna mess with me yeah
didn't think so the stairs doesn't look
bad for an indie horror game might be
unity engine
I'm sure unity engine is if you don't
know it's a really good free game engine
this helps people pump is what the
Slender games are based off I think I
think they're based off the Unity engine
I'm not quite sure at least parsec
productions one was based off of the
Unity engine okay doors locked
did I try to ah I forgot that enter was
the use key so we got some over here my
headphones are loud again really quiet
didn't expect and to be cowboy blood
that looks good
ooh a key hey oh that ha ha ha ha
I saw her I saw you I saw that guy oh
boy can I get up there
no no I saw that guy hello is anybody
out there anybody home
anybody wanna mess with me uh what I
didn't think so
oh no wait no there was a lot during the
beginning there hang on let me go try
this key on that first I see a door over
there but open I since this is right
here oh this is where that guy went
what's with those cracks in the walls
they just cracks her I have like freaked
out because an SCP and time you see some
like black stuff on the ah-ah-ah blocks
oh so scary
Oh free chili did I failed why am i why
do I keep bouncing off this box you like
a push this box I can Boosh it oh I push
you
hey was that first aid marker Oh who's
out there who's out there
past fail why do you have boxes of
failed a whole box of fail what was in
this room I'm curious actually don't
know if there's anything either way I
guess this keycard ply unlocks the door
I saw up there I'm gonna give it a
little look I'm trying to I'm trying to
watch out for said black shadow man that
I saw that kind of looks suspiciously
like radical Larry from SCP containment
breach but I'm not sure I am Not sure is
anybody out there
hello hello huh huh can't have me too
handsome
Oh tough strong what that snake you
under there you under that box
what hello
oh no not going in oh I'm not going in
there no thank you no thank you at all
hello okay
oh it's a briefcase I totally forgot
about the briefcase
I forgot while I was in here okay I have
a brief good huh oh no oh no oh no oh no
oh no oh no oh no oh oh through the back
through the back through the my good
thing I don't know
oh that ah I hear something okay alright
okay oh this is gonna kick me out where
I was ah you called their attention let
me up there let me up there I want to go
up that one how long ago oh alright I
got this
I just got to get home right I gotta get
to my fan know what I'm doing
now what I do I can sprint right okay I
can sprint I'll save it I don't know if
I'm gonna be monster chase
oh right there are those it no I'm gonna
go Google oh I was right there ah ah
baloney baloney I'll count it again ah
right there unfair I turned around and
looked it alright fraction three two one
thing oh man oh right right there right
there any munched on my brain oh how are
there's like a it's like a floaty guy on
a sheet oh no all right so I know what
to do now I'll just do it quickly Bank
briefcase and get out get out get out of
my face all right sure it's printing Oh
God
Go Go speed running oh man put it I
Turner I always do that I always turn
around whenever they I hear noise
don't check to see what it is while is
trying to eat your brain rule number one
a horror that I still haven't learned
I've been playing horror games for about
six months
I don't know what's wrong with me I'm a
big dumb idiot ah her Wow
come here come on come on nibble on your
brain after I get out of here okay now
get to brief gate oh no crap I keep
forgetting it's gonna get up get it and
get up get up ah bein held can it get up
get in get up get in get up get it get
up get in get out get in and get out
it's like this place so who will get in
and get out
excuse me like I have this weird feeling
that it knows that I failed and it's
gonna try to get me again early on I'm
not sure if there any surprises in this
game but I just get it get it get it
coop okay
all right I got it run run run run
running running running okay block back
something wants at me bad
sorry I'm not home
go away go mess with someone else uh go
go go go sprint Britt sprint sprint
I don't think there's any cool down on
Sprint's on sprinting hmm don't look
back don't look back go down around this
time I'm too brave for you didn't get in
enter huh
awake yeah yeah I did it is it it's like
a same ending it just goes to blood
uh-oh
does it okay well that was anticlimactic
I was two inches away from getting the
exact same type of ending all right then
okay well that was it I was interesting
I still don't know who who made I made
that game let's see game freeware Oh
Brandon Matisse mattis Brandon mattis
that's the name on the email so um the
link to download it is in the
description below
I'm click on that if you want to play it
yourself but I mean there's not much
more to it I don't think I don't think
there was anything else it could have
been done I don't believe anyway so I
think that's it so thank you all so much
for watching click the annotation for
more videos that I've done and as always
I will see you in the next video bye bye